thank you very much
Estie indeed I'll describe observations
but I'll also describe a theory
astrophysics theory which mathematicians
may regard is close to observations but
we think of it as theory and I wanted to
start with this slide since today is the
evening of the Chinese New Year and so
on the left you see a depiction of PHA a
goat I mean it does look like a goat and
that's the symbol for the new year
on the right side you see actually what
nature produces which looks pretty
similar to that except that it's on the
scale of a hundred thousand light years
and what you see here is a jet ejected
by a central black hole that we can't
see a tiny region of space that produces
this huge jet stretching across the
entire galaxy and here in the middle you
see the dust rain of that galaxy and so
to celebrate the new year we might as
well look on this side and that will be
the side that I'll focus on in this talk
so the topics that I'll this discuss
today are several I'll start with
imaging black holes silhouettes the
black hole itself is a dark region it
doesn't emit any light but material
around it emits light and it that the
black hole casts a shadow and I'll
discuss it we have the technology
actually to image that shadow and then
talk about pairs of black holes black
hole binaries just like with humans when
you put two black holes together they
form a binary system that is stable if
you put a third one it's unstable
just like with humans again and then
I'll discuss the recoil of black holes
as a result of either a merger of a
binary or a triple systems
black holes kicking one of them at large
speeds then I'll discuss the fate of
stars near black holes in particular we
wrote a couple of papers over the past
few months with a postdoc James will
adjourn about the possibility of
accelerating stars like the Sun close to
the speed of light which is quite
remarkable if you think about it and
near black holes and the near a pair of
black holes and the pair of black holes
acts as a slingshot that ejects a star
if a star gets too close to a black hole
it can be disrupted by the tide that is
raised on the star just like tides
raised raised by the moon are observed
in the oceans on earth when you get
close to a black hole the tide is so
strong that a star can be ripped apart
and finally I'll discuss the possibility
that very small black holes may have
been produced in the Big Bang and in
principle they can account for the dark
matter in the universe whose nature we
don't know so the story starts a hundred
years ago actually exactly a hundred
years ago this is a special year during
which there are lots of conferences
celebrating the general theory of
relativity Einstein wrote the equations
and published the first paper around the
November to 1915 and a month later cars
watered found an analytic solution to
the equations that Einstein did not
appreciate he was at that time he was at
the German front after he joined the
military in Germany and he sent a
postcard to Einstein telling him that he
found an analytic solution for a point
mass Einstein was thrilled to get this
postcard and communicated its content to
the Berlin Academy and a year later
koshwal chill died at the German front
so the lesson from this story is that if
you want to work out the full
consequences of a theory for an extended
period of time you better off being a
pacifist because ice both of them were
German Jews the difference was that
instan was a pacifist and Karsh watch it
was a patriot so he volunteered to the
German army he was back then the
director of the Potsdam Observatory
nevertheless he gave up on his academic
pursuit joined the army and fought and
found his death within a year but he
managed to solve to find this solution
by the way when I mentioned this joke in
a colloquium I gave in Germany that was
not much laughter in the audience and
Schwarz solution is actually the full
solution for a point mass in spherical
symmetry and it's characterized by a
singularity physical singularity in the
middle meaning that if you were to make
a black hole by collapsing a star or a
cloud of gas then the density of the
matter will diverge at the given point
in space and at that point
Einstein's theory of general relativity
breaks down that's why we call it a
singularity that means that the theory
is incomplete and we know why it's
incomplete because on very small scales
you have to incorporate quantum
mechanics so we have the fear of quantum
mechanics on the one hand the theory of
gravity on the other hand and we would
like to marry the two Einstein himself
try to do that without success these
days there are hundreds of or maybe
thousands of string theory is attempting
to do that it's one of the frontiers in
in theoretical physics but we don't have
that theory as of yet so at the moment
we don't really know what happens near
the singularity of a black hole it would
be nice to know one way to find out is
to jump into one of these Astrophysical
black hole
I'm talking about problem is that once
you get there you won't be able to write
a paper and publish it because the
information cannot go out a black hole
is the ultimate prison you can get in
you can check in but you can never check
out and there is this horizon the
Schwartzel horizon at a distance of
twice times Newton's constant times the
mass of the black hole divided by the
speed of light squared inside of which
there could be no communication to the
outside world what you see here as these
lines are trajectories of photons
particles of light that have zero mass
if they are directed towards the black
hole they get absorbed if they are
directed from this point outwards they
may escape and there is this photon
orbit that for ash watch it black hole
and on spinning black hole is one and a
half times the Schwarzschild radius
where a photon can execute a circular
orbit so in fact at that radius if you
were to look straight you might see your
back because photons coming from your
back will reach your head so a photon is
gravitationally bound to a circular
orbit at this radius and you can see
that in principle what an observer at
infinity sees if the observer is sitting
on this side of the black hole the
observer will see a shadow cast by the
black hole so the question is what
happens to an observer close to the
black hole and and that question was
addressed in the movie interstellar
and to address this question Kip Thorne
in collaboration with a very with a
variety of people imagined a camera
located near a black hole and ask what
will the camera see taking into account
the effects of the deflection of light
gravitational lensing and translation
and so forth and that's the image that
they came up with for a black hole
surrounded by a disc of gas that is
emitting radiation that you can see in
the movie
frankly I I I didn't enjoy much this
movie because the science was not
accurate and the plot other than that
was not particularly exciting but but
this is the image produced and in fact
it was just posted on on the archive on
Astra pH last week so you can read more
about it in this archive paper how they
produced it in the past people
scientists did not really worry about a
camera next to a black hole because
nobody wants to be close to a black hole
so in fact we want to test the structure
of space-time near a black hole to check
whether choix chilled was right a
hundred years ago and so one aspect of
it is testing the general theory of
relativity the other one is testing the
physics of gas accretion the info of gas
into the black hole usually because of
the strong gravity the black hole sucks
matter from the surrounding galaxies and
that's the matter we see and so the over
the past 30 years or so there were
theories for how this matter behaves in
particular if the matter is called
it makes an accretion disk in which
matter just like near a faucet matter is
spiraling into the black hole by losing
angular momentum through viscosity or
viscous stress and we would like to test
these theories by now there's numerical
simulations of that process the second
aspect as I mentioned is testing general
relativity in the strong gravity limit
so the one important aspect of switch
watchit solution is the existence of an
event horizon which is a one-way
membrane matter can fall in but cannot
get go out and if there was a hard
surface of course matter in pinching on
the black hole would radiate much more
energy so we can easily test whether a
black hole horizon exists if we could
image the vicinity of the black hole
there were some papers recently talking
about quantum effects that may show up
in the context of four
example fire wars something like a
surface although it may be hidden just
behind the horizon so if there is
anything pathological anything unusual
that may exist around the black hole we
would like to see it there are of course
paradoxes about black holes for example
the information paradox matter falls in
carrying a lot of degrees of freedom a
lot of information but the black hole
itself can be characterized only by
three numbers its mass its spin the
level of rotation that it has and its
charge and in astrophysics black holes
do not have significant charges because
if it had a charge opposite charges will
be immediately accrete onto it and
cancel each charge make make it neutral
so we actually have only two numbers and
the question is where does this
information go and of course there is
the process of Hawking evaporation where
radiation is emitted from the black hole
so perhaps that carries some of the
information but recent studies of that
process say that no it's actually not
there so this is an unresolved the
puzzle in fundamental physics the
information paradox there is also the
breakdown of general relativity at the
singularity that I spoke about before so
clearly black holes are good
experimental laboratories for getting to
study physics beyond the standard model
that we have right now so let's say talk
about the black the biggest black hole
closest to us which is black hole at the
center of the Milky Way galaxy
Sagittarius a star we know that it's a
black hole because we can monitor the
orbits of stars close to it just like
planets in the solar system tell us what
the mass of the Sun is we can infer that
the mass of the central object is about
four million solar masses four million
times the mass of the Sun and it's very
compact the tightest orbit of star of a
star around the black hole is as big as
the solar system and so we within as
scale of the solar system we need to
pack four million times the mass of the
Sun no way of pack there is no way of
packing this with ordinary matter such
that the matter would be stable and not
collapse to a black hole and so we are
pretty confident since we don't see that
matter and it looks like a dark object
that is weighing a lot and it's
extremely dense that this is a black
hole now not only over the past three
years we haven't only seen stars
orbiting the black hole in in one set of
observations that was actually evidence
for a cloud a gas cloud approaching the
vicinity of the black hole this is an
artist's depiction a simulation of the
behavior of the gas cloud in fact this
particular simulation with the in which
the cloud is held by external pressure
is ruled out because as you can see from
the date when the cloud passes near the
black hole it was supposed to be
disrupted and it was not actually passed
earlier this year or a few months ago
the cloud was discovered back in 2012
and you can see how it moves on the sky
it moves it as at the speed of a few
thousand kilometers per second and it
has roughly the mass of three Earth's
and the size of the solar system roughly
and you can see the trajectory of this
cloud here in bracket gamma radiation
this is a particular line of hydrogen
that allows us to trace the cloud
relative to the background one there are
various ways of making such a cloud one
is to have a star in the middle that we
proposed with ruth-marie clay here at
the Center for Astrophysics another one
which appears more plausible at the
moment is a model that we proposed with
the postdoc James village shown were the
this cloud is one out of several pees on
on a bead so these are honest you can
imagine a stream of gas on in that
fragments into clumps and one of these
clamps is passing near the black hole
right now there are more clumps along
the way and this stream of gas was
produced by ripping out the outer
envelope of a star so there is a star
which is not in the middle of the gas
cloud it's somewhere else but it
basically shed off a fraction of its
envelope and that's the stream of gas
that is now clumping and we see one of
these gas clouds and when I was asked by
the New York Times about what the origin
of this cloud might be I was able to say
something that made it to the quotation
of the day but a year ago I said that
the experience is as exciting for
astronomers as it is for parents taking
the first photos of their infant eating
and the experience here is watching the
black hole being spoon-fed
by a star passing near it so astronomers
do like to watch this process going of
spoon-feeding the black hole in real
time during our lifetime we can see this
cloud moving around the black hole and
possibly feeding it now the special
thing about Sagittarius a star that this
black hole at the center of the Milky
Way is that it's the largest on the sky
if we wanted to image the silhouette you
would like to look at the black hole
that is the biggest on the sky and this
is Sagittarius a star and one can
imagine sending a technician for example
this Verizon technician from a
commercial a few years ago that goes
around and asks can you hear me now you
can send that person to the vicinity of
Sagittarius a star and you can imagine
what would happen as this person gets
closer and closer firstly it encounters
the he encounters the inner most stable
circular orbit
and that means that if once he gets
inside of it he cannot move on a stable
circular orbit around the black hole
that's at three times the Schwarzschild
radius then he gets to the photon orbit
which is one and a half times the Swart
radius eventually gets to the Schwartz
Ragus now nothing would happen to his
body at that point because the black
hole is four million solar masses the
tidal force across a couple of meters
roughly the height of that person the
difference in force between his legs and
his head is not large the overall
acceleration is almost a million times
the acceleration on the surface of the
earth but it acts almost uniformly on
the body of this person so a person in
freefall actually doesn't feel anything
due to gravity this was Einstein's
insight that if you are in a
free-falling elevator you won't be able
to tell that you are in a gravitational
field and so the only way to tell is if
there is a difference in forces between
your head and your toes and that
actually happens eventually within ten
minutes this person once it crosses the
photon orbit within ten minutes it will
reach the singularity and then be ripped
apart and of course we would see from
outside this person getting redder and
redder with his voice getting sort of
dilated we when never seen him crossing
the horizon but from in his frame of
reference he would actually fall all the
way to the singularity within ten
minutes
black holes were called originally
frozen stars because people thought of
it if you make a black hole from a star
that is collapsing at infinity you see
the matter only reaching the horizon so
it's sort of like frozen image and by
the way the same frozen image occurs in
cosmology now it seems like the universe
has a horizon the de sitter horizon and
when we look at galaxies as they exit
from the de sitter horizon in the future
their image will be frozen just
like in the context of a black hole in
fact there are lots of similarities
there so one way to probe the space-time
that is very effective is to put a clock
around the black hole that is moving in
orbit and you might think oh how do I
cut a clock in orbit I mean if you don't
want to risk a technician going there
you might do it remotely and we do have
precise clocks in astronomy in fact the
almost as precise as the best atomic
clocks and these are called pal stars
these are neutron stars that emit a beam
of radiation and they the emission
Direction is processing around the spin
axis of the neutron star and you see it
like a lighthouse you see a beacon of
light passing the telescope every so
often
hurry Adak lee and by timing the arrival
time of these pulses you can measure
time and if there is a pulse or near
Sagittarius a star that would be
fantastic we could actually map
space-time so that we proposed back in
2004 and over the past decade no pulsar
was found in the vicinity of such a star
only except for last year actually two
years ago 2013 there was a pulsar
discovered serendipitously by chance
unfortunately this particular pulsar
which is very highly magnetized it
called the magnetar is located a
fraction of a light year away so it's
not really very close to the black hole
and the search is on for finding paths
close in so imagine a hot spot not a
pulsar a hot spot in the accretion disk
moving around you see it in the upper
right panel and that's the way the
observer would see it and here we are
tilting the orbital plane as a function
of time and you see that the image of
this hot spot looks quite different
depending on the inclination angle there
is one side that appears brighter than
the other side and this is simply
due to the Doppler effect that the
beaming as material is moving in the
direction of the observer it shines more
brightly due to special relativity there
is also the effect of gravitational
lensing photon trajectories are
deflected by gravity so you can get more
than one image and in fact there are
several images that one gets you see it
here in blue and green depending on the
orientation of the orbital plane
relative to the observer there is the
primary image from the hot spot and then
there is the secondary image where the
photons are moving around the black hole
and are seen from a different direction
and finally there is a third image which
is much fainter where the photons
execute a full circle around the black
hole and come back on the other side and
altogether one gets an image that looks
like a crescent of the moon for example
and you can see this Crescent here
it depends that the exact shape of this
Crescent depends on the inclination of
the orbital plane so what you've seen
the top panel is a hot spot orbiting 30
degrees from the line of sight without
any spin to the black hole so that's
what you would get here again a non
rotating black hole - watch it black
hole with no spin but at 10 degrees
inclination and at the bottom panel you
see a rapidly spinning black hole and
you can see that the Crescent looks a
bit different of course in all of these
crescents there is a dark region due to
the fact that when radiation is emitted
behind the black hole it gets absorbed
the black hole catches these photons as
I was mentioning before and you get a
silhouette a dark shadow of the black
hole and this shadow is the signature of
the event horizon the scale of this
shadow is of the order of 50 micro arc
seconds so if you are an amateur
astronomer
and you use a back a small telescope in
your backyard you can perhaps under the
best visibility conditions reach
resolution angular resolution of a few
arc seconds here we are talking about a
resolution which is a factor of a
hundred thousand better and obviously
even the biggest telescopes in the
visible light in optical ban cannot
resolve such scales right now however
there is a there is a way of detecting
it as I'll mention in a few minutes the
spin of the black hole matters because
the scale of the horizon depends on the
spin so here I plot the size of the
horizon in Swart chilled radius units as
a function of this norm normalized the
dimensionless spin parameter so a
maximally spinning black hole has a spin
parameter of one a counter rotating
black hole spinning to the opposite
direction has spin parameter of minus
one this is a black hole spinning at the
speed of light opposite to the direction
of motion of a test particle and you can
see that the size of the horizon becomes
roughly half the Swart you'd rather use
in fact exactly half the Swart radius
for maximally spinning black holes then
there is the inner most stable circular
orbit which is abbreviated as east core
and that's the the smallest radius for a
circular orbit that is stable around the
black hole and for a counter rotating
orbit this is five times the Swart
radius for co-rotating test particle it
is the Swart chilled it is ash water
arrives for a maximally rotating black
hole and it is roughly three swatching
radii for low spin then there is the
concept of the relative efficiency in
principle if matter can orbit on a
circular orbit it can release its
binding energy in radiation and the
tighter the orbit is the more
ashin can come out so the efficiency of
converting rest mass into radiation
depends on the radius of the ESCO the
inner most stable circular orbit and for
a spin parameter of unity it can reach
42% so in fact you can think of black
holes is very efficient engines that can
convert up to 42% of the rest mass of
material into radiation that's the most
efficient engines except for engines
based on an inhalation of matter for a
non spinning black hole the efficiency
is 5.7 percent now here you can see
simulations of an accretion disk that
has to balance in a which showed the
image that an observer at a large
distance would see and there is still
this shadow and crescent shape in red
here but it's it also has some small
scale structure due to the turbulence
and there are lots of details in such
simulations that we are not sure about
for example how the radiation is
produced but roughly speaking all of
them show this crescent shape with a
shadow in the middle now why do we hope
that to actually detect this shadow to
constrain it mother nature was very kind
to us it's not always the case there are
problems in physics where you can work
for decades like the problem that string
theories are trying to tackle and you
are still not sure that you're on the
right track but in this case mother
nature was very kind to us and there
because there are three fortunate
coincidences one of them is that the
matter falling into Sagittarius a star
is transparent to radiation with a
wavelength shorter than one millimeter
and we are talking about radio waves
emitted
by the material so Sagittarius a star
was originally detected in in the radio
at wavelengths shorter than one
millimeter the material falling into
Sagittarius a star right now is
transparent to the radiation to
synchrotron self-absorption which is the
dominant absorption process and this is
just now if more material were to fall
into Sagittarius a star in the future it
would be opaque we won't be able to see
all the way through another coincidence
that has nothing to do with the first
one is that when you look at Sagittarius
a star at radio wavelengths there is
intervening matter in the inner galaxy
which is blurring the image scattering
the radio waves and it turns out that
this blurring becomes insignificant
again for wavelengths shorter than one
millimeter so we can actually see the
image of this silhouette without being
without the image being blurred by the
interstellar medium of our galaxy and
finally a third coincidence is that the
scale of the horizon of Sagittarius a
star and also the horizon of the black
hole in a giant galaxy called the m87
that is much farther away from us can be
resolved as long as you build a
telescope with an aperture that has the
diameter of the earth for a wavelength
of one millimeter so in other words the
resolution of a telescope is the
wavelength of the radiation divided by
the size of the aperture that you can
read in any textbook on optics so if you
take the wavelength of one millimeter
and ask how big should my telescope be
in order for me to resolve the shadow of
Sagittarius a star you find that it has
to be just the size of the earth okay
that sounds ridiculous how can you build
a telescope as big as the earth but it
is possible in fact there was a senior
thesis back in the 60s that a student
wrote with John Wheeler
on imaging black holes and the student
concluded that it's not feasible and
then moved to work in a different sub on
a different field he is now a professor
at UC Davis and I actually contacted him
and I said said to him that it was the
wrong move because we can actually do it
now but it's too late I guess and so
these are images of the shadow of
Sagittarius a star at different
frequencies of radiation the higher the
frequency or the shorter the wavelength
the less blaring you get by the
interstellar medium and also the less
absorption you get by the material next
to the black holes you get sharper
images and the way to construct a
telescope as big as the earth is to have
stations distributed around the earth
and here you see the view of the earth
from the direction of Sagittarius a star
so if you were to sit on such a star and
look at the earth this is what we would
see and you see here a number of
millimeter observatories that can detect
radiation at a wavelength of one
millimeter and if you were to measure
not just the amplitude of the
electromagnetic wave that arrives at
these stations but also the phase you
can correlate the arrival phase of the
wave and in principle if you have a
large enough number of stations you can
produce an image with a resolution on
the scale of the black hole horizon and
in fact this observational project is
led by chef Dolman that is sitting
somewhere in this audience over there
with his son is it yes and the idea is
to connect these observatories and
correlate the signal that is detected at
the different stations so far we have
looked analyzed data from three stations
that were correlated and I'll talk about
that in a minute in principle
there is this concept of the event
horizon telescope the full-fledged
system of all these telescopes connected
to each other not just three of them and
to show you an example of what such an
array of stations can do here you see a
simulated image of Sagittarius a star
with lines indicating the polarization
of the radiation coming from the
material near the black hole this study
was led by Mike Michael Johnson a
postdoc at the Center for Astrophysics
and you can see the polarization
directions and this is what the event
horizon the full event horizon telescope
would be able to produce to reconstruct
from the observations and we will not
only get a sense of how strong is the
magnetic field near the black hole but
also its orientation so that can be used
to test theoretical models for what how
the gas behaves in the vicinity of the
black hole right now the event horizon
telescope is composed of these three
stations one is in Hawaii it's called
the submillimetre array SMA related or
led by the Smithsonian Astrophysical
Observatory of the harvard-smithsonian
Center for Astrophysics and the second
is JC MT nearby two that in Hawaii and
then another station is in California
it's called Karma the abbreviation for
that is this is number two and number
three is the in Arizona and these three
form a triangle that can be used to set
constraints we can't get an image of the
shadow but we can set constraints on it
and in fact in a paper that we published
almost five years ago we try to fit the
emission spectrum from Sagittarius a
star and get the best fit model to the
set of observational constraints that
were available at that time and we ended
up with the conclusion that there is a
probability distribution for spin per
and it's most likely a very low spin for
this black hole we got a probability
distribution for the inclination angle
and another orientation angle so this is
good we get close to Sagittarius a star
but but no cigar in the sense that we
don't have an image yet there is another
galaxy that I mentioned it's called m87
it's a giant elliptical galaxy sort of
the type of galaxy that we will become
that the Milky Way will become once it
merges with Andromeda galaxy its sister
galaxy and so the black hole inferred in
the middle of m87 has a mass that is
much larger than the mass of Sagittarius
a star by some three orders of magnitude
'm almost a factor greater than than a
thousand fourteen hundred times more
massive than Sagittarius a star but it's
at a distance that is 2,000 times
greater than the distance of Sagittarius
a star because this is the distant
galaxy but if you take the ratio of
these two numbers you get the number of
all the unity meaning that we can in
principle hope to image the shadow of
this black hole there is a big
difference between m87 and the Milky Way
in the sense that there is a jet just
like the jet I had in my first slide
celebrating the Chinese New Year this is
the jet that you have in a in m87 and
it's a very tightly collimated jet going
all the way out and usually theoretical
models that produce a jet require the
black hole to have a high spin and so
this black hole we know has a high spin
probably and these are theoretical
similar models of what the shadow around
such a black hole might look like and
the different assumptions that's a paper
that we wrote with every broderick when
he was a postdoc in our theory group and
you can see that the image near this
black hole depends also on what you
assume about the base of the jet and how
the emission takes place in the vicinity
of the black hole so you can get
different images
it's not just dependent on the spin but
it does depend on the spin and this is
from a nature paper led by Shep
published a couple of years ago where
the size of the meeting region was
constrained to be smaller than the inner
most stable circular orbit for a non
spinning black hole so the conclusion
from this paper was the black hole must
have a spin because we can see a mission
from a scale the base of the jet is
coming from a scale that is smaller than
the Isco for a non spinning black hole
and in fact if you do a detailed
analysis trying to fit the image you get
that the spin has to be pretty close to
unity the spin parameter has to be
bigger than 0.9 or 0.96 depending on
assumptions about the mass of the black
hole now obviously if there is a black
hole at the Centers of galaxies and
almost every galaxy has a black hole at
its center when two such galaxies merge
you make a black hole pair the Milky Way
itself will merge within a few billion
years with Andromeda galaxies we see
this galaxy coming at us the night sky
will change it would be a spectacular
event to watch actually as the Andromeda
galaxy is colliding with the Milky Way
but we see these events on the sky quite
frequently and here is an example where
you see two cores of galaxies coming
together and are many more such examples
where you see two cores of galaxies
coming together at different separations
so here the separation is close to 30
thousand light years at the top left and
at the bottom right the separation is
less than six thousand light-years and
beyond that below that separation it's
very difficult to separate with the
resolution of these telescopes separate
the two cores but we believe that such
cores of galaxies spiral
towards each other because of friction
gravitational friction dynamical
friction on the background matter
background stars and gas and eventually
the black hole themselves get very close
to each other after the stars
surrounding them gets stripped and then
eventually they come together due to the
emission of gravitational radiation so
here you see two black holes close to
each other in x-rays so this is a galaxy
that has a lot of dust you can't see
much through the dust but in x-rays just
like in the airport you can actually
image the center of this galaxy and tell
that there are two centers of light and
here you see a double black hole system
in the radio and these black holes emit
jets so you can see two jets coming off
here is another example there are plenty
of examples this is the tightest black
hole observed in the radio the
separation is around 20 light-years and
the total mass is estimated of the two
black holes is estimated to be about a
billion times bigger than the mass of
the Sun so one way to tell that the
binary exists is to look for periodic
variation of the light and I analyzed
this signature about five years ago
where I argued that in principle you can
find these binaries by looking for
periodic modulation of the light and if
you ask what would be the characteristic
period when for example gravitational
radiation takes over and starts to be
dominant at the dominant mechanism of
bringing these two black holes together
compared for example to the friction on
the surrounding gas then you find that
the period is convenient it's about
seven years comparable to the duration
of a PhD thesis in our department not
sure how long is the PhD thesis in math
but you can always imagine the two black
holes coming even closer
and earlier actually just a few weeks
ago there was a paper published in
nature arguing that perhaps there is
evidence for such a system where the
period is of order five years the
evidence is not very strong because they
have observed this system only for about
eight years
but it's indicative when more data is
needed to figure out if indeed this is a
system that gets to the point where the
rotational radiation takes over and this
binary black hole system will merge in
less than the age of the universe due to
the emission of gravitational waves now
you don't have to stop at two black
holes as I mentioned even among humans
there are triple systems and that can
happen for example if two black holes
are in the process of coming together
and then another galaxy comes in and
joins the party and then you can get
three black hole systems and we
calculated in some papers with Jewish
Kulkarni and Loren Hoffman the
likelihood of getting such triple
systems and we figured that in fact
these are unstable and and one of the
black holes gets gets ejected with
speeds that can exceed a few thousand
kilometers per second
so in principle such a speed would imply
that the black hole crosses the diameter
of the earth in a few seconds okay so
these are very high speeds and such
black holes with escape from their host
galaxies so you can find these ejected
black holes in the intergalactic medium
no in fact the most common cases are
once in which you have the third body
being less massive because or two of
them being less massive because they're
men
more of those than massive black holes
here we see a pair of black holes coming
together by the emission of
gravitational radiation and this problem
was very challenging to solve
numerically with computer codes until
about five years ago where a
breakthrough was made and and right now
it's there are codes that solve
Einstein's equations in vacuum except
for two point masses orbiting each other
in full and calculate the emission of
gravitational waves and that's what you
saw here now it turns out that when the
two black holes come together eventually
they get to the east core the inner most
stable circular orbit and then the small
black hole plunges into the big black
hole
so the gravitation waves are emitted in
a preferred direction and by
conservation of momentum there is a
rocket effect the remnant black hole
that results from the measure of the two
black holes gets kicked in the opposite
direction and what you saw on the right
hand side is that the kicked black hole
the recoiled black hole could in
principle escape from the host galaxies
and so these numerical simulations were
able to calculate what is the recoil
speed and we incorporated that into
galaxy merger simulations with my former
student Laura Blanca and found that you
could find recoil black holes moving out
of galaxies just due to the
gravitational wave emission the rocket
effect from that and then a question
arise arose as to whether such systems
are found on the sky and the best
candidate for such a system is shown
here these are two centers of light that
represent two black holes and they are
they have a relative speed of about a
thousand kilometers per second and an
offset of around seven thousand
light-years just a month ago we posted
on the archive and
interesting suggestion for detecting
gravitational waves so these
gravitational waves that are emitted by
black hole pairs have very low
frequencies they have a characteristic I
mean the two black holes even in the
disco have an orbital time of order a
thousand seconds if they have the mass
of Sagittarius a star so we're talking
about a wave period of order a thousand
seconds or a wave frequency of amelie
Hertz and NASA together with ISA the
European Space Agency are promoting a
concept to detect these waves in space
you can't do it on the ground because
there is seismic noise but you can in
principle put laser beams separated
apart that will measure the slight
change in distances between the lasers
as the gravitational wave is passing by
and that's the concept for a mission
that is planned for launch 20 years from
now just measuring the change in
distances using interferometry this is
called the ELISA mission now we thought
of something different just over the
past year the precision of atomic clocks
improved dramatically by orders of
magnitude and so our suggestion was to
use atomic clocks to detect
gravitational waves and the idea is as
follows
there was a historic experiment that
tested Einstein's theory of gravity done
at Jefferson Lab the building next to
this one where the physics department is
it was done by pound and Rebka so here
you see one of them at the basement of
jeff Jefferson Lab talking on the phone
with his colleague at the top of
Jefferson Lab and measuring the
frequency of gamma-ray photons emitted
by nuclei at the top of the building to
be different due to the
gravitational redshift due to the fact
that the gravitational field of the
earth changes the frequency of the
photons and using the most power effect
they were able to reach a very high
precision that allowed them to see this
tiny shift due to the Earth's gravity so
here is the earth causing the
gravitational shift now imagine moving
the earth under the experiment back and
forth tying it with a rope and pulling
the earth and then pushing in well one
way to do that is to put another earth
in a binary orbit then obviously what
pound and Rebka would find is a time
dependent time dilation effect or time
dependent gravitational redshift effect
that is changing periodically this is a
gravitational wave so if you have a
precise enough clock then you should be
able to detect gravitational waves and
the idea that we proposed was now with
the precision of atomic clocks that in
particular optical lattice clocks the
technology of optical lattice clocks one
can reach a precision of order 10 to the
minus 18 one part in a million trillion
in other words over the age of the
universe
such a clock would not be off the exact
time by more than a second over 10
billion years and if you put such clocks
in a triangular configuration for
example around the orbit of the earth
around the Sun and you shine laser beams
that communicate the ticking rate of
each clocks you would be able to tell
that one for example if there is a
passing gravitational wave and the two
clocks are separated by 1/2 of
wavelength then you would be able to
tell that they are ticking at different
rates now this is different from
measuring changes in distances the
current design of ELISA because you're
basically measuring the change in the
ticking rate or the frequency of the
clocks relative to each other
you're not you don't care about the fact
that the distance changes you just care
about the fact that the clocks are not
ticking if they were synchronized to
start with you can record that they are
ticking at different rates at 1/2 a wave
period at one time one clock is faster
than the other and half a wave period
later it's the other way around and this
repeats periodically so this is a
different concept than interferometry
for measuring distances and well the
issue of comparing it to interferometry
is a subtle one and we are looking at it
now but the point is that the precision
of these clocks of 10 to the minus 18 in
in fractional time precision is
comparable to the amplitude of the
gravitational waves that you would get
from a binary black hole system that has
a mass similar to Sagittarius a star at
a jig a parsec okay in fact such a
binary system at the Jigga Pathak will
have 10 times the amplitude you can see
it here the amplitude is almost 10 to
the minus 17 at a distance of Jigga
parsec or 3 billion light years for
black holes with a million solar mass at
a frequency of a milli hertz
which actually corresponds to half a
wavelength comparable to the orbital
radius of the earth around the Sun okay
so that's the convenient coincidence
that the orbital rise of the earth
around the Sun is just corresponding to
the type of frequency you get from a
binary black hole system and such a
binary system in fact will coalesce
within 10 wave period so if you catch it
it's very close to coalescing in and the
period the wave period will change with
time there is this chirp that makes the
period get shorter and shorter as the
two black holes get closer and closer so
you can actually not only infer the mass
of the system but also the distance
because you have two equations one
telling you how to hear the wave period
or the wave frequency changes with time
and the other one telling you what the
wave amplitude is and you can constrain
the mass and the distance from this now
when two black holes come together and
one of them gets recoiled that means
that black hole can get ejected from the
host galaxy so there is actually an
interesting prediction that one can make
the Milky Way galaxy was made out of
building blocks early on in the universe
there were smaller galaxies dwarf
galaxies that came together to make the
Milky Way galaxy so the earlier
generations of galaxies were smaller
than the present-day galaxies that we
have and so you can imagine that
whenever two dwarf galaxies came
together the two black holes at their
centers joined and due to a
gravitational wave emission the merger
remnant got recoiled now the
gravitational potential of the host
dwarf galaxies is relatively shallow
much shallower than that of the Milky
Way it's usually it corresponds to
speeds of all the 10 km/s whereas the
Milky Way has a potential well of 200
kilometers per second so the black holes
typically get ejected with the speed of
order a few hundred kilometers per
second or less and so such black holes
would get expelled from the host warf
galaxies but they would still remain
bound to the region that eventually
makes the Milky Way and so what you
would end up with are floating black
holes in the hellos of the Milky Way
galaxy that's a prediction from this
process and there should be of order a
hundred such black holes we analyzed it
in a paper with my former a graduate
student Ryan O'Leary and they should
carry very compact star clusters that
were taken with them so you can look for
these compact star clusters and we
looked at the survey of the sky called
the Sloan Digital Sky Survey and found
some candidates for those that have to
be looked at more carefully another
interesting phenomenon can take place is
you have two black holes with their star
clusters due to the merger of two
galaxies it turns out that the two black
holes tend to get into eccentric orbits
by scattering background stars they tend
to plunge towards each other and when
the secondary black hole for example
gets very close to the primary black
hole the stars around that are tightly
bound to the secondary black hole can
get expelled this is a slingshot effect
imagine the two black hole acting as
slingshots and they eject the star
gravitationally then you can end up with
stars that are moving almost up to the
speed of light and together with James
bulletins we calculated the statistics
of such stars and we found that there
could be stars reaching almost the speed
of light so think about it if you are
sitting if you are occupying a planet
next to such a star this would be the
journey of your life the star would be
ejected from the host galaxies move
through the universe traverse it close
to the speed of light so you would be
able to look at a vast volume of the
universe almost you would almost make
the journey of a photon through the
universe and we are talking about real
stars you know them
stars like the Sun or more massive than
that but of course the numbers of very
fast stars is small that there are more
stars moving less than the speed of
light we call them semi relativistic
hypervelocity stars and we define them
as new cosmological messengers because
if you if you look at the literature on
studying the universe the study of
cosmology people use primarily photons
particles of light okay and here you
have the opportunity to use material
objects that move almost the same speed
as photons and bridge across
cosmological distances so these are new
cosmological messengers and if you ask
how many of them other within let's say
a distance of 3 billion light years
one Giga parsec depends on the on the
speed but you know there could be 10 to
the power 15 such stars moving at a
speed that is about a tenth of the speed
of light but fewer of them moving at the
speed close to the speed of light of the
order of a few thousand now when such
stars move across the universe this is
the metric describing our universe as it
turns out our universe is very simple
once again nature was kind we think we
might know why but not sure yet
basically geometry is flat okay so the
sum of angles in a triangle that you
draw through the universe and as you
note Riemann originally wanted to figure
out if the if space is flat or not by
drawing triangles we now know that on
the scale of the universe the universe
is flat okay so you can describe it with
them and it's also expanding so this is
the metric of a flat spatial component
of the metric expanding with a scale
factor that is changing with time so the
spatial scales are being stretched with
time and then there is the time
component that is ticking at the same
rate everywhere in the universe and if
you have material objects instead of
photons that are emitted from a galaxy
then their velocity would be degraded or
would be reduced as time goes on due to
the expansion of the universe the way to
think of it is that in quantum mechanics
every particle has a debroglie
wavelength and the de Broglie wavelength
of a particle is just like the
wavelength of light it gets stretched by
the expansion of the universe and so for
a massive particle could be a star or
anything that the broadly wavelength
scales like one over the momentum or one
over the velocity and it's being
stretched like the scale factor so
therefore the velocity is reduced
inversely with
scale factor and that's indifference
from photons where the velocity speed of
light is constant so you get a different
relation between distance and travel
time then you get four photons and and
you get a change also in the brightness
of the star due to relativistic beaming
and a star could get deflected by an
intervening galaxy due to the
gravitational effect of that galaxy the
effect is similar to gravitational
lensing and so we calculated those
effects and you can find them in our
paper if the star gets too close to the
black hole then it can get ripped apart
by the tide as I mentioned and such
events occur once per hundred thousand
years for galaxies that have a single
black hole but the rate can be enhanced
by almost a factor of a thousand for
black hole pairs and black holes that
are too massive like more than a hundred
million times the mass of the Sun they
would swallow the star hole they would
not repeat repeat apart because the
gravitational tide would be too weak but
but black holes that are less massive
than a hundred million would rip apart a
star like the Sun and the feeding rate
of the black hole would be huge and it
could lead to outflows so here you see a
simulation that was made by my
collaborator Kimi hayasaki with my
former student Nick stone where you see
a star being shredded into a spaghetti
like stream of gas this is called
spaghetti ization of the star and you
can see this stream going around the
black hole in this case the black hole
has a spin and it's counter rotating
it's with a spin of minus 0.9 when the
chance of the of the stream intersecting
itself is actually larger than if the
string the stream was pro-grade moving
in the same direction as the spin of the
black hole and so you see the stream
intersecting the stream of gas this is
the XY projection this is the
y'see projection of the same process and
eventually the material intersects
itself and makes an accretion disk
around the black hole now this is the
case where the gas is cooling very
efficiently so the stream becomes very
thin in the simulation this simulation
was completed I mean the paper was
posted just last month and it's it
represents state-of-the-art calculations
of this process if you allow the gas to
cool very efficiently the situation is
quite different you can see here that
the stream becomes very thick because it
heats up due to the stream stream
collisions and then you make a torus of
gas that is rather thick around the
black hole much more quickly the tidal
disruption rate could be enhanced if the
black hole has a recoil for example when
two black holes come together the would
be gravitational wave emission and after
that the black hole will be kicked and
then it will see fresh material that it
can eat along the line of sight so it
can actually capture stars along the
path of the recoil and produce many more
tidal disruption events we found with
Nick stone we found that roughly every
hundred years in such a case you can get
a disruption of a star so there is a
chance that the PhD student would see to
such events coming from the same galaxy
and in fact a couple of years ago there
was actually more than that three and a
half years ago there was one tidal
disruption event of a star observed at
the cosmological distance that likely
produced a jet pointed at the observer
and we can see such a jet because it's
so bright all the way to the edge of the
universe and an interesting question
about the jet is whether the jet will be
aligned with the spin of the black hole
or whether it will be aligned with the
orbital plane
I mean perpendicular to the orbital
plane of the debris from the disruption
of the star because the debris from the
disruption of the star has no knowledge
of the spin axis of the black hole so in
Prince
can be aligned at an arbitrary angle and
then the question is where will the jet
go will it be aligned with the angular
momentum vector of the orbit of the
original star or with a spin of the
black hole turns out that since this
system with a jet was seen steadily for
two weeks without changing in brightness
we can rule out the possibility that
there is precession of a jet around the
black hole spin axis and the most likely
situation is that in fact the jet was
aligned with a black hole spin so that's
the conclusion we drew from that now let
me get to my final topic which is
primordial black holes black holes
produced in the Big Bang and in
principle if you imagine the universe at
early times it was seeded with density
perturbations in homogeneities and if
you have a density enhancement of all
the unity across the scale of the
horizon of the universe the universe
it's the horizon of the universe will
collapse to make a black hole but since
the horizon is very small at early
cosmic times you would make a tiny
microscopic black hole with a
microscopic mass so this could be for
example the dark matter you could have
some real perturbations that made up the
dark matter because we won't be able to
tell
now Hawking evaporation would eliminate
all the black holes with masses less
than an asteroid mass but black holes
with masses more than 10 to the 15 grams
more than the size of an asteroid and
the mass of an asteroid have an
evaporation time that is longer than the
age of the universe so they should still
be around if they existed and
interestingly enough such a black hole
that has an asteroid mass has the size
the Schwarzschild radius of the size of
a proton ten to the minus thirteen
centimeters so if such a black hole
passes through a proton it will
disintegrate the proton into quarks just
due to gravity that's quite remarkable
so just like I was talking before about
destroying star
here we are talking about destroying a
proton with a black hole passing through
it due to the gravitational tide and a
surgical passage of such low mass
primordial black holes through the earth
is difficult to detect because the only
thing it does is excite seismic waves so
the question is is the dark matter made
of such black holes could it be
primordial black holes and we wrote a
couple of papers with a postdoc that
worked with me Paula pani were ruled out
the possibility that the dark matter is
made of such black holes and the first
part of the argument had to do with
black holes with a mass between the mass
of the moon and the mass of the Sun okay
and it turns out that if you take a
black hole and surround it with a mirror
and this was argued back in the 70s you
take a black hole put a mirror around it
a reflecting mirror and let radiation
bounce back and forth if the black hole
has spin it will turn it turns out that
the spin energy of the black hole can be
converted into low-frequency
electromagnetic radiation with a
wavelength comparable or with a
frequency comparable or lower than the
spin frequency of the black hole and you
get a black hole bomb because the the
black hole radiates these waves they
bounce off the mirror
come back just like in a laser they
bounce back and forth between the mirror
and the black hole and they get
amplified every time and so you build up
an energy density inside this cavity
spherical cavity such that eventually
you'll get an explosion all you need to
do is surround a black hole with mirrors
so is that at all just an academic
exercise well for decades people thought
but but then it occurred to me that in
fact in the early universe you know if
you look at these primordial black holes
they were so much surrounded by a mirror
it's called plasma or ionized gas and it
turns out that when you write the
dispersion relation for a photon in an
ionized gas in a plasma
you can think of it as a massive
particle the frequency squared is equal
to the plasma frequency squared plus the
wave number square times the speed of
light squared that's similar to having
the energy squared of a massive particle
equal to its mass squared times the
speed of light to the fourth plus its
momentum square times speed of light
squared so in fact it's as if the photon
acquires a mass and if you think about
it how does the mirror operate when you
look at the mirror you see your
reflection the reason you see a
reflection is because the plasma
frequency inside the metal there is a
silver coating to the mirror to the
backside of the glass which is basically
a metal and that has free electrons in
it electrons that are free to move and
it has some characteristic plasma
frequency related to the density of
these free electrons and you are looking
at at light where the frequency is
smaller than the plasma frequency and
therefore the light gets reflected
that's what the mirror is so if you look
at this primordial black holes and they
are surrounded by a dense enough plasma
in the early universe they will act that
the plasma will act as a mirror and you
can extract the spin energy of these
primordial black holes it's very
difficult to imagine them being formed
without any spin they would likely be
formed with spin and you can extract
this energy and now as time goes on this
mirror will eventually disappear because
the universe is expanding and the plasma
frequency will go down the density of
matter would go down and so you will end
up with the energy that was stored
inside this cavity being dissipated into
the radiation field in the universe and
so you can end up with the energy
distorting the Cosmic Microwave
Background and we have limits on that so
by using those limits you can actually
rule out the possibility this is the
fraction of the dark matter that is in
the form of primordial black holes as a
function of their mass and this mass is
roughly the mass of the moon here all
the way up to the mass of the Sun or we
can rule out the possibility that
primordial black holes with even a
little bit of spin are the dark matter
based on the fact that we haven't seen
energy injection into the Cosmic
Microwave Background during the later
history of the universe so that's one
argument then for lower mass black holes
that had a mass of the order of an
asteroid mass less than the mass of the
moon you can rule them out by
considering neutron stars so if such a
black hole passes through a neutron star
very dense star then it turns out that
it will excite modes inside the star and
eventually get trapped and sink to the
center of the neutron star and start
eating up the neutron star so turns out
if you do the calculation and that's a
very detailed calculation that the
existence of neutron stars in the
Centers of galaxies where there is a lot
of dark matter rules out the possibility
that the dark matter is made of
primordial black holes with masses
between the mass of an asteroid and the
mass of the moon
and once again you know the the limits
are quite significant so let me
summarize the punchline of my talk and
in the first part I talked about the
event horizon telescope a very exciting
frontier that many of us are involved in
and in fact we are now collaborating
with and the rominger from the physics
department with Peter Galison that was
here and with SDI on this project
together with a number of astronomers
and the goal is to image the silhouette
of the black hole at the center of the
Milky Way galaxy and in m87 and
constrain general relativity or
deviations from from general relativity
observational ii and then i mentioned
the existence of pairs of black holes
black hole binaries and that can be
looked for in electromagnetic radiation
they can also accelerate stars
close to the speed of light which is
quite remarkable acting as slingshots
and when they coalesce they get recoiled
and so you can look for offset black
holes from the center of galaxies and
also for floating star clusters in the
Milky Way galaxy and finally primordial
black holes probably do not make up the
dark matter in the universe thank you
I'll be glad to answer questions
especially from the students in Andy's
class 211 are black holes from A to Z
okay go ahead so the question the
question was what is the source of the
radiation that we see coming from
Sagittarius a star this radiation is
thought to be emitted by electrons
relativistic electrons gyre